spam for pricing information or to
request a tape or go online to c-span
org slash shop and click on book TV on
Cambridge University's campus in 1946
two philosophers Ludwig Wittgenstein and
Karl Popper squared off in a ten-minute
exchange rumored to have led to victim
Stein brandishing a red-hot poker
next BBC journalist david edmonds
co-author of Vidkun Stein's poker
discusses what actually happened in this
now legendary clash and how it reflects
the development of philosophy and the
times this program runs 50 minutes good
evening everyone it's nice to see such a
big crowd on a cold evening like the one
we have I'm John Teague I'm the general
manager here at politics and prose on
behalf of Barbara Mead Carla Cohen the
owners and the rest of the staff it's a
pleasure to welcome tonight David
Edmunds the author of one of the most
unique books in recent memory vacant
Stein's poker I discovered the book
because our sales rep at a book
convention said here you're the one that
likes these odd little books I'd like
you to have this which is great after 30
years I'm now known as the guy who gets
the weirdo books and I took it home and
put it aside because the last thing one
expects to find had a book convention is
a good book but one night bored with
whatever book I was reading I picked it
up and started looking at it and I was
immediately captivated it's a wonderful
story of human beings of massive ego and
brilliant intellect and somehow slyly
david edmonds and his collaborator have
woven in a complete history of 20th
century philosophy this is quite a feat
and I am very pleased to introduce now
the Preston
tater david edmonds thank you very much
and it's good to see so many people on
such a cold night it was a night very
similar to this on October the 25th 1946
that we wrote about except we have
radiators and warmth they had nothing
but a fireplace and of course a poker
since writing the book the question that
has come up most often people ask me how
can you write a whole book about just 10
minutes 300 pages about just 10 minutes
and indeed he doesn't seem a very
productive way to spend ones time it
took two years of my time two years of
my co-authors time four years of writers
time altogether to write about these 10
minutes I estimated recently that had we
chosen instead to write a book about the
Hundred Years War then operating at
approximately the same pace it would
have taken us nearly 22 million years to
complete October the 25th 1946 8:30 p.m.
you haven't a room in Cambridge one
small man with enormous ears by the name
of Karl Popper you also have a chap by
the name of Ludwig Wittgenstein very
intense human being and as a third man
there as well he's in his 70s shock of
white hair craggy neck bit like a
chickens
he's called Bertrand Russell three of
the greatest philosophers of the
twentieth century meeting for the one
and only time let me tell you Papa's
version of events Papa is there to
address the moral science club the club
for students and for university Don's at
Cambridge the title of his paper is are
there philosophical problems he begins
his paper he gets about thirty seconds
in before the chair of the meeting
Ludwig Wittgenstein interrupts give me
an example of a philosophical problem he
demands popper says something like the
problem of infinity fitna Stein
dismisses that as a question of
mathematics popper offers another
example Pitkin Stein dismisses that - by
this stage Pitkin Stein is getting more
more angry more more agitated and he
bends down and he picks up the poker
which is by the fireside and at some
stage and this is according to Papa
at some stage Ficklin Stein says to Papa
give me an example of a moral principle
whereupon popper replies thou should not
threaten a visiting lecturer with a
poker
according to popper victims die and then
throws the poker down storms out of the
room and slams the door behind him Papa
is left victorious on the field of
battle that is Papa's account
Papa's have been accused of lying
the great-circle papa a man with more
than 20 honorary doctorates Margaret
Thatcher's favorite philosopher a man
fated by Helmut Kohl by the Dalai Lama
by prime ministers and presidents around
the world the accusation is that Sir
Karl Popper lied in his account of that
meeting and it was to investigate that
accusation that we began and eventually
finished this book the first thing we
needed to do was to track down the
eyewitnesses there were probably thirty
people in the room that night we located
nine of them spread all around the world
now you're 30 people in the room there's
probably three times as many people here
to listen to reading about the meeting
then with them we're in the meeting at
the time but the first extract I'll lead
is when we're beginning to introduce
some of the eyewitnesses for the full
story of the confrontation between Vic
and Stein and papa
we must wait until all the evidence is
in but there can be no better place to
start than with our eyewitnesses
conventionally we should feel a chill in
the air as a glance around the room
summons up the ghostly crowd waiting for
dr. popper to begin his paper and picks
out our 9:00 from now return to youth
from among them inevitably the eye goes
first to the crowning intellects of the
evening in front of the fireplace
placidly smoking his pipe is the
silver-haired Bertrand Russell to
Russell's left facing the audience isn't
apparently quiet and insignificant
figure Karl Popper
one or two of the undergraduates are
noting his prominent ears altogether out
proportion to his small stature to joke
about over a pint after the meeting
popper is taking the measure of his
adversary whom he has thought about so
much but until now never actually seen
fit conspire the club's chairman sitting
to Russell's right
he too is small but filled with nervous
energy passing his head over his
forehead as he
waits to open the meeting and looking at
Papa with those penetrating blue eyes
and their intensely white and large
surrounds ficken Stein and Papa our
reason for being here but now the eye
moves on to the young Palestinian
graduate Westby he jab he's clutching
the moral science club minute book in
which he will later pen the
understatement describing the
confrontation of the evening the meeting
was unusually charged it was hid jab
who'd sent the neatly handwritten
invitation to Papa and negotiated a
change of date from the club's habitual
Thursday to Friday to suit the guests
like all set secretaries he feels
responsible for the guests showing up
and threats about his arrival until he
actually sees him in the flesh
Papa's firm handshake is an early sign
that his slight frame conceals an
assertive personality sitting nearby is
one of Papa's closest friends in
Cambridge Peter months but searching for
postgraduate degree in history months is
one of only two to have studied under
both Vidkun Stein and Papa he was taught
by Papa in New Zealand who in the war
and as a transparently earnest bright
student just a few weeks earlier had
been welcomed by Bickman Stein into his
seminars months were calls Papa pacing
slowly across the room throwing and
catching a piece of chalk and never once
breaking stride and speaking in long and
perfectly constructed sentences now he's
encountered Vidkun Stein who wrestles
visibly with his ideas holding his head
in his hands occasionally throwing out
staccato remarks as though each word was
painful as plucking thorns a muttering
goddamn stupid today or shouting damn my
bloody soul help me someone so the book
spins off into many different directions
one thing that interested us was
Bertrand Russell and his relationship
between the two men to both he was
something of a father figure
Papa thought that he was the greatest
philosopher since Immanuel Kant and
particularly admired the way Russell
could churn out book after book and
never had to rewrite a single sentence
whereas Papa would strive to construct
his books and would go over the time
after time after time
before he was happy with them victim
Stein and Russell's relationship was
very close and had it not been for
Russell victim Stein probably never
would have gone into philosophy in the
first place and so here's a section
about victim Stein and Russell Fitness
dying arise in Cambridge in 1911 by 1911
the 22 year old Ludwig has become
preoccupied with the philosophy of
mathematics
his father had wanted him to have a
technical education so he'd already
spent two years in Berlin and three
years in Manchester studying Aeronautics
building experimental kites and
eventually designing an airplane engine
now he felt compelled to turn to
philosophy and following conversations
with British and German mathematicians
he sought out the internationally
renowned logician the Honorable Bertrand
Russell of Trinity College Cambridge
some eight weeks later having passed the
autumn term as a guest student at
Trinity fitness Stein requested the
answer to a simple question was he
utterly hopeless at philosophy Russell
did not know what to think
Finkelstein returned to Vienna to write
something for Russell to look at the
result of his endeavor declared Russell
was very good much better than my
English pupils do I shall certainly
encourage him perhaps he will do great
things by the summer of 1912 within six
months of victim Stein taking up his
full-time place Russell had come to
believe that he had discovered his
intellectual heir krypton Stein was he
thought perhaps the most perfect example
I've ever known of genius as
traditionally conceived passionate
profound intense and dominating he later
repeated this view to an American
confidant Lucy Donnelly his avalanches
make mine seem miss snowballs he says
that he says every morning he begins his
work with hope and every evening he ends
in despair kiss just the sort of rage
when he can't understand things that I
have soon their teacher-student roles
were reversed for the first time in his
life Russell felt intellectually
overpowered in 1916 in a letter to his
lover the socialite lady Ottoline Morel
he mentioned an incident three
years earlier when Vidkun Stein had been
severely critical of some work Russell
had been doing in the field of
epistemology
although Russell could not fully
comprehend victims nights inarticulate
comments they were sufficient to
convince him that he himself was wrong
his criticism though I don't think he
realized it at the time was an event of
first-rate importance in my life and
affected everything I have done since I
saw he was right and I saw that I could
not hope ever again to do fundamental
work in philosophy Vickers time
persuading me that what wanted doing in
logic was too difficult for me not long
after he admit fitness Stein Russell
said in a letter to lady Ottoline I love
him and field he will solve the problems
I'm too old to solve and after a year
Russell told Ludwick's elder sister her
Mina who was in Cambridge visiting the
baby of the family we expect the next
big step in philosophy to be taken by
your brother their early relationship
was one of mutual respect and affection
Russell was an emotional sheet anchor
for victim Stein who would often go to
Russell's room and paced up and down in
silence are you thinking of logic or
your sins
Russell once asked both came the reply
sometimes victim Stein's mood was so
savage that Russell feared he would
break all the furniture in his room that
story about Wittgenstein asking Russell
whether he should continue in
philosophies which is repeated by
Russell in various different versions
there's in his autobiography and in the
BBC archive there's a version of it
Russell had this very kind of
high-pitched voice which I'm not sure I
could carry off but he says something
like Vidkun Stein came to me and he said
am I an idiot because if I am an idiot I
shall become an engineer
so Russell dispatches him to Vienna and
asked him to write something and fitness
Stein comes back I read one line and I
said Wittgenstein you must not become an
engineer another area that fascinated us
was was Vienna and and there's a big
chunk of the book about Vienna both fit
concern and Papa came from what might
seem similar backgrounds both from this
small town both of Jewish extraction
both both their families have converted
papa was born a Protestant victim Stein
was baptized a Catholic and Vienna was a
very small place they knew people in
common that Papa's family was a friend
of Sigmund Freud sister Sigmund Freud
was a friend of Vidkun Stein sister and
she's actually been psychoanalyzed by
him on his famous couch you would
expected them to be friends but in fact
there was this world apart that perhaps
we can talk about in questions popper
was a member of the bourgeoisie his
family was a lawyer but he losted his
entire wealth in the hyperinflation of
23 and the economic depression in the
late 20s where's victim Stein's wealth
was beyond the bounds of imagination he
the victim Stein's were perhaps the
richest family perhaps the second
richest family in Austria and victims
Don himself was said to be the richest
man in Austria when his father died in
1913 and he inherited the Vidkun Stein
wealth there was also the connection
that they both had with the Vienna
circle the most fashionable philosophic
or movement in the world in the 1920s
and 1930s the Vienna circle essentially
believed that statements to be
meaningful had to fulfill one of two
criteria either they had to be
analytically true true in virtue of the
meaning of the language for example to
two equals four all bachelors are
unmarried men Socrates's man all men are
mortal therefore Socrates is mortal true
and virtual of the language or they had
to be verifiable they had to be testable
I'm now in Washington you can poke me
and prod me and you can tell I'm here
water boils at 100 degrees centigrade
the vienna circle deified Vidkun Stein
they read the only work he produced in
his lifetime the Tractatus
logico-philosophicus they read it not
once but twice and they went over every
sentence Karl Popper always wanted to be
a member of the VINs beyond a circle but
he was never let in by the Vienna
circles founder a chap called Marge
slick and one of the reasons he was
never allowed in was because of his
opposition to Wittgenstein now the
vienna circle came to an end in 1936 and
here's why shortly before 9 o'clock on
the morning of the 21st of June 1936
Marge slick left his apartment
overlooking the board formal gardens of
the belvedere palace at the top of print
Eugene Strasser boarded tram D running
gently downhill towards the center of
Vienna and began his familiar 15-minute
journey to the University of Vienna
where he held the chair in the
philosophy of the inductive sciences he
got out a few yards from the stone to
stone steps that led up to the imposing
main entrance how he'd through the iron
gate and along the cavernous central
hall and turned right up the stairs
towards the law and philosophy rooms the
54 year old professor was already late
for his lecture on the philosophy at the
natural world in which he would he would
examine such topics as causation and
determinism and whether men have free
will as he hastened to his lecture
waiting for him on the stairs that day
was an unwelcomed figure a former
doctoral student Johann L book Nell book
had twice been committed to psychiatric
wards for threatening slick and had been
diagnosed as a paranoid schizophrenic in
part his obsession with his erstwhile
supervisor had to do with a fellow
student Sylvia by avika with whom Nell
book was infatuated
herself of a somewhat nervous an
unstable disposition she had rebutted
all his advances and had compounded what
tournelle book was an incomprehensible
error of judgment but expressing
romantic thoughts for the professor of
inductive sciences it's not clear
whether slick married to an American and
with two children reciprocated her
affection no matter in no books mad
imaginings the two were having a torrid
affair nor was this the only injury he
believed he'd suffered at the
professor's hands following his spells
under observation in the clinic no but
could be gonna frustrating and largely
futile quest for work his rejection for
one job caused a festering wound a
lectureship in philosophy at an adult
education center have been delighted to
him only when his history of mental
illness which he tried to keep hidden
was exposed for this to Nell book blamed
slick the man whose complaints had first
landed him in mental Clare he brooded
over retribution sometimes during
lectures on the analysis of propositions
or the nature of truth when slick
glanced up from his notes that gaunt
respectable bespectacled figure of Nell
book would be staring back from among
the rows of students nor was there any
respite back in print Eugene Strasse
where telephone calls would carry
insults and menacing threats the
professor usually saw unruffled was
terrified he admitted as much to friends
and colleagues he alerted the police and
took a bodyguard but after a time when
the intimidation came to nothing it was
decided to dispense with his protection
and slick ceased all contact with the
police I fear he told a colleague they
begin to think that his I who is mad at
9:15 a slick reached a half landing on
the stairs to the philosophy wounds Nell
but pulled out an automatic pistol and
fired four times at point-blank range
the fourth bullet which is lodged in
Slick's leg was superfluous the third
bullet could have the third bullet had
pierced the colon and stomach and the
first two had punctured the heart
professor dr. March slick died instantly
today a brass inscription marks the spot
what was interesting about that murder
was that
in Vienna it was widely believed that
for some reason that slick must have
been Jewish which he wasn't and that the
killer nail book must have been carrying
out a political act against what was
seen as a Jewish philosophy namely the
philosophy of look of the Vienna circle
logical positivism and nail book
although he got a prison sentence was
soon to become kind of Viennese hero
kind of fated for his political action
and he was he was let out shortly after
the war had began so I say we spin off
into various different directions one
thing that made the confrontation so
fierce was the personalities of our two
protagonists stuck there were stories
stories abound that would make your eyes
water about their brutality in
discussion and debate and as for my
final reading I'll just read you a
section about Sir Karl Popper whatever
the social and cultural differences
between Vic and Stan and popper one
similarity of character made it
inevitable that h3 would see a raging
confrontation their sheer awfulness to
others in discussion and debate
physically small and exhausting the
intense neither man was capable of
compromise both were bullying aggressive
intolerant and self-absorbed though
victim Stein once pitched himself more
appealingly to norman Malcolm being
timid I don't like clashes particularly
not with people I like popper strategy
in argument has been described by Brian
McKee Berlin's score through identifying
minor faults popper would carefully
strengthen his opponents case before
demolishing its core point meeting him
for the first time Magee was struck by
an intellectual aggressiveness such as I
had never encountered before everything
was pursued beyond the limits of
acceptable conversation in practice it
meant trying to subjugate people and
there was something angry about the
energy and the intensity with which he
made the attempts the unlimited fierce
tight focus like a flame put me in mind
of a blowtorch
while one of poppers major contributions
to scholarship was the insight that for
a theory to be scientific it must be
open to falsification he was never happy
to accept the application of this
principle to his own ideas it's been
said that the open society and its
enemies should have been renamed the
open society by one of its enemies
professor John Watkins concedes the
popper was an intellectual bully in
seminars there were famous cases where
someone announced his title what is X
and Papa would interrupt what questions
are completely misguided a recollection
from the days spent at the LSE by the
author and journalist Bernhard Levin an
admirer of popper reinforces the point
one day at a seminar a fellow student
offered an opinion couched in terms
greatly lacking in coherence the sage
frowned and said bluntly I don't
understand what you are talking about my
hapless colleague flashed and rephrased
his comment our city teacher now I
understand what you are saying and I
think it's nonsense well I'll stop there
because I think my time is up and open
it up to questions and promise not to
accuse any of your questions with being
nonsense if you could I've been asked to
ask you when you ask a question you need
to stand by the mic because it's being
recorded by c-span and otherwise they
won't be able to hear you and so and
I've been told not to respond if you ask
question and you'll not by the mine I am
by the mic all right good when I read
the book I was struck by Vic and Steen's
almost craziness I mean he wanders off
into the into the woods he wanders up to
Norway he gives all his money away he's
trashes around all the time I'm
wondering if you have any thoughts from
from your reading and discussions if if
that sort of mindset and that sort of
character might have had some kind of
influence on where he ended up
philosophically I'm not sure it affected
where he ended up philosophically I'll
just fill in some background for some of
the other
he was in the habit of disappearing he
would go off to Island he would go off
to Norway he would disappear off the
southern Austria on his own he built a
hat in Norway for himself because he
wanted to solve all the problems of
logic and just an example of how
extraordinary a personality he was and
what a spell he cast over people he went
to Norway in 1913 he was a relatively
young man can a recent graduate from
Cambridge and he demands of the very
famous professor Cambridge professor GE
Moore who with Bertrand Russell is one
of the two philosophical pillars of
Cambridge University he demands of this
internationally renowned philosopher the
great G more that G more go to Norway
and effectively take dictation and more
did it and more was very was he didn't
like traveling he got seasick he had to
travel by boat he was violently ill and
he sits there well if it can stand
dictates to him in answer to your
question I think it didn't affect his
philosophy so much his extraordinary
personality but I think it probably has
affected his legacy and you know this
book wouldn't exist had it not been for
Vikram Stein's personality and they were
now on the shelves hundreds of books
about Vidkun Stein both about his
philosophy and about his personality and
there was biography that came out about
ten years ago by Ray monk I called the
duty of genius which can fine a fine
book about it because he makes them have
a snide comment about people who knew
that cos then almost everybody who knew
Vidkun Stein writing a memoir about him
they only need to have to met him five
times and they would write an essay
about him such an impact did he have on
them so I think it didn't affect his
philosophy which changed dramatically
during the course of his life and it did
he did a u-turn in his philosophy from
there was the later Wittgenstein in the
early victims time we can talk a bit
about the philosophy but I don't think
it has affected his the way he's
remembered it's probably the reason he's
so inspired so many kind of artists and
novelists and so on in part because of
the personality that you talk about
because one of the one of the things
that struck me was first of all I think
two of his brothers committed suicide
li3 sorry and and he contemplated
himself and he gave his money away my
sense in reading about him and I don't
know him as well as as you do I'm sure
but is that he tried to get away from
what we would call him what he would I'm
sure shrinking back when we if we said
this but the real world I mean he tried
to get away from the kind of
confrontations with reality that popper
took on with a vengeance and they seem
like they're from very different worlds
but it seems that that victim Stein's
personality and his character in
something in his psyche pushed him away
from that way of looking at the world
and that's sort of what I was getting at
for Mike right um
again some biographical background he
was he was one of eight children the
five boys and three girls his three
eldest brothers all killed themselves
his father who had been this business
June genius who transformed Austrian
have been the moving force in the
Austrian industrial revolution was
clearly a bully and a tyrant and his
artistic brothers who wanted to become
musicians and creative types were under
pressure to go into business and you
know it was too much for them and and he
as you say victus not himself was
constantly suicidal as in fact was
Bertrand Russell was one of the things
they had in common I think how that
affects his philosophy is his his lack
of compromise you know if you look at
something like Bertrand Russell who is
prepared to publish things that may not
be perfect well may be far from perfect
in Bertrand Russell's
case victim Stein was the opposite of
that everything had to be pure and
truthful and honest he didn't really
disengage from the world I mean in some
ways when the world required it he went
out and sorted so to give you an example
of that in the first world war he didn't
need to fight in the first world war he
was a victim Stein the victims nineties
didn't need to fight in the first war
although it concerns could easily ignore
being drafted or he demanded to be
selected in for the Austrian army and
then insisted that he had one of the
most dangerous positions in the Austrian
army telling people about artillery fire
equally in the Second World War he
played a role so he wasn't
I don't think divorcing himself from
reality like that his obsession with
language which continues from the
beginning to the end of his life has its
roots in Vienna and Vienna circle as
well and Karl Kraus also was very keen
on language but I think it's I think
that doesn't that that has less to do
with his personality than than the
philosophical Miglia from which in which
he came
yes you need to get all the way over
there way otherwise I'm gonna refuse to
españa I hope you don't mind I'm gonna
philosophically disagree with you you
mentioned that Russell Russell was
bitten science advisor and Russell was
Vince I see that advisor yeah and
Russell's whole objective in his
Principia and work was to formalize the
science that everything has to be rigid
and as you pointed out Victor instead
made a u-turn okay he basically said
after he did his thesis this is not true
you can't fix meaning that everybody has
their own interpretation of words and he
has start Lee not just at the popper
incident but you know every time he had
a meeting with people he would always
when somebody said something what do you
mean by that
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by that and it wasn't just that
situation and it really his nothing is
nothing is is fixed here you know
whatever you say I'm gonna question it
and he did that with Turing he did that
with a lot of people and it was this
that you pointed out the language issue
that I really think right but and some
people see that as destructive the fact
that he was you know what do you mean
what you mean but another way of looking
at it is it kind of liberates he was
liberating people from their
philosophical problems some
philosophical background the Vic Vic
with early Vidkun Stein believed
essentially that language somehow
mirrored the world language pictured the
world a a sentence like the book is on
the desks the podium somehow pictured
the way the book actually was on the
podium and that somehow language had to
do that to make sense it had to be a
mirror image of the world the later
victim Stein turns that around
completely and the later Wittgenstein
believes that we are in charge of
language is not the world that dictate
it's linguistic concepts to us but we
who can map out any description of the
world that we so choose
so in Ann Arbor where I'm based for a
few months it might be very useful to
have lots of words for snow
for example whereas in Venezuela it
might be less useful but it's entirely
up to us to divide the world up as we
want and that was his kind of linguistic
revolution that has been so influential
in so many different areas and but it's
it's the obsession with language that
links the early victim Stein and the
late victim Stein it instantly and that
is what the debate with popper was all
about popper thought well it's all very
well analyzing language but it's just
like cleaning your spectacles or
cleaning the windscreen it just helps
you see the world better it's not an end
in itself
it's a means to solve real deep
philosophical problems which popper
believed existed in the world in which
he was going to devote his entire life
to solving I'm done hi my name is Heidi
Lee Feldman and you've just mentioned
Ann Arbor I should tell you that I did
my doctorate in philosophy in arborist
and my JD at the law school there and
I'd like to ask you a question I'd like
to make a comment and I'd like to share
two quick anecdotes and I'd let you do
all of this without seeming like an
obnoxious hog are you trained did you
bring a philosophical background yes I
study philosophy there oh but they must
think you're sold out because why are
you talking about what was going on at
the Cambridge moral sciences yes it is
it's the other side I know all right
the comment I wanted to make on the sort
of philosophical front the sort of back
and forth that's been like I said hasn't
been a back and forth exactly it's been
a triangulation
is that I mean in some sense both the
earlier if it can shine and the later
Vickers shine and poppers throughout his
career I mean they have I don't think
that Vickers shine is interested in
getting away from getting away from
reality
he becomes increasingly suspect about
whether traditional philosophy can
grapple with reality so and that is
freaking him out I mean and you can see
it in the work and then the
transcriptions of his work so this
question he thinks that philosophers
pose questions which are supposed to be
about reality but the questions can't
possibly be about reality and it's in a
way I mean his fierceness towards popper
it's like you know I in my view the way
one reacts to the person whose views
represent what you wish could be true
wondering if you had any comments on
that yeah no I'm sure that's absolutely
right and I mean I think one other thing
which is common throughout his
philosophical life and it's summed up in
the last line of the tracked artists
we're off one cannot speak thereof one
must remain silent one thing that's
common throughout his philosophical life
is that there are some things which he
would love to be able to grapple with
like morality which he thinks philosophy
is incapable of responding to and
philosophy and the analysis of problems
is not the way you get to an ethical
life although he's got that interesting
piece about about the moral imperative
being categorical and he doesn't know
what to do with that but that's an aside
I very quickly my thesis advisor was
supervised by popper James Peter Elton I
don't know if you've met him in Ann
Arbor but he's a quite prominent moral
philosopher and philosopher of science
interestingly and he is certainly
capable of all the mobbing call it
meanness I prefer to say bluntness of
philosophers
but I represents a sort of effort to
synthesize to sort of bridge the chasm
that these two seem to have force
themselves into and there are a lot of
philosophers today who have done that
I do remember Peter Alton saying to me
well sitting in a seminar with him
earlier my graduate career and he said
well surely you agree that pain is bad
and I said why and we were off and
running so the legacy was handed down
but and the other good story is I had
the opportunity although she was quite
old Elizabeth Anscombe give one of the
lectures that I attended at Cambridge
and she was in Vicki and schneid circle
as I'm sure many people here know and
she came in and she had sort of like so
Charlotte she was actually knitting
while she was lecturing and somebody she
would do that right somebody raised
their hand to ask a question and she
basically said the equivalent of shut up
you [ __ ] but in some sort of cultured
British way that I can't do yeah we
learned that habit from her from her
mentor she's just actually society just
died a few months ago because I look
with her fondly as the old man yes I I'm
a lifelong devotee of Vicki Steiner was
a philosophy student I did some graduate
work at the University of Nebraska under
its boughs MA right and I'm one of those
one of these one of those guys who's
written a memoir yes yes and but I'm one
that also took Vicky Stein's advice
which was to give up for those of a
break and get a real I think it's
important I just wanted to sort of
comment on some of the previous comments
with regard to Vidkun Stein in real life
I think that it can be fairly said that
you know he wouldn't have
acted so many followers and and as many
went out of philosophy has remained in
philosophy to become you know compelled
to do the kind of thing that he did but
I think he I think one of his most
telling remarks was that for the highest
compliment he could give to anybody was
that that was a real human being and I
think that his he was this he had this
he was grabbed by these puzzles and
that's why this you posed it as the are
there philosophical problems are there
philosophical puzzles and Vidkun shine
was drawn to that puzzlement and he said
he couldn't help it but he you know
would encourage so many people to you
know unless you're compelled to do this
right get out of it and I'm a plumber
and I'm a good plumber but what had been
it was very damaging to quite a few of
his disciples this insistence that they
give up philosophy some of them were
quite academically gifted and there were
two or three examples of working-class
kids in Cambridge who he got to know who
he encouraged encourage he's not exactly
the right word with it Ben Stein to
abandon philosophy one of whom could
hardly who so uncoordinated he could
hardly tie his shoelaces together and
Vic maslany insisted he go and get a
proper job working with his hands and I
think some of the parents of some of
those disciples resented this influence
and saw him coming very much is kind of
evil demon can is just your modus
operandi for writing this book with your
co-author did one of you take one
position and the other or it could never
been written without the internet
really it was a Internet book and John
would begin one section I would begin
another and then we'd bat it back and
forth back and forth by email using that
a tool in in Microsoft Word with where
you can you can see all people's
revisions yes it draws a line through
your deletions rather than getting rid
of it and puts your additions in a new
color and so you could see what the
other author do it's not an easy process
where our editor in London first time we
went to go and see him we had this idea
he said well it's good idea for a book
but in my 15 years of being an editor
there's I've never had a single case of
two authors still being friends at the
end of the process let's say but we are
detailed question about the book there
is an image that sticks with me between
the truck terrace and then his other
work he worked as a school teacher in a
grade school in the country and there is
an image where he is he having an
argument with his sister I think and his
sister reproaches him you know why are
you wasting your genius on kids and on
school kids great school and then he
uses that image you are just you know
like a person through the window
who looks through the window and cannot
understand the efforts and I like the
metaphor but I have several
interpretations for it and I would like
to know if the image is something like
he says to Amina you'll like the person
who looks through the window and sees a
man dead wobbling unsteady on his feet
and doesn't realize that there's a kind
of gust of wind outside and I think the
way I interpret that is that Viktor
Stein was on the very kind of edge of
madness suicide insanity
yes throughout his life and just trying
to hold on and he completed the tracked
artists in the trenches of the First
World War
he'd spent altogether eight or nine
years working on it he was
intellectually exhausted
he believed he'd solved every
philosophical problem there was to solve
in this little slim tiny book there was
nothing more to say on philosophy so off
he was going to say he became a gardener
in a monastery
he went to teach in little primary
schools where he several primary schools
where he got into trouble for for
hitting one or two of the kids and then
he spent two years building this
incredible building which if you ever in
Vienna you must go and see it in could
man gasps which is now the Bulgarian
cultural attache with the attention to
detail which is kind of you know we've
described some of the anecdotes in the
book about about how he drove the
builders absolutely barmy because they
would just be finishing the job then he
would insist that the ceiling was raised
three millimeters and they would say mr.
engineer does one does one millimeter
really make so much difference and he
would say yes before they had a time
chance to finish the sentence and but
it's a wonderful beautiful building
which is now I went to a lecture a few
months ago in London just on this
building it's considered important I
think now in the history of architecture
thank you I was wondering if Pitkin
Stein had done any work on philosophy of
mind and what do you think he would make
of our present-day computers internet
instantaneous communication and the
possibility of artificial intelligence
he and he knew chewing and did he almost
get in a fight with chewing I'd that I
didn't that that I didn't know but I
mean some people say he kind of helped
chewing solve the Enigma code and one
one thing that Victor Stein well it's
not clear what he says but some people
interpret Vikram Stein to say it doesn't
matter if there's a contradiction
because if you if a community wants to
live with a contradiction in mathematics
well so be it it's up to them languages
use you use it as you
if you want to live with a contradiction
that's fine and chewing an expert in
kind of artificially intelligent like
that idea and it was it was using the
idea of contradiction that helped him
solve the Enigma code he there's a lot
of stuff on victim Stein in the
philosophy of mind but it doesn't go
into the science he cut he was
interested in questions like can I know
you're in pain can I know I'm in pain
those sorts of questions in the
philosophy of mind and again with those
he dissolved them by saying let's look
at what we mean by no can I know I'm in
pain I can't know I'm in pain because
knowledge of my own pain makes no sense
because you can only know something if
you can doubt it I'm deluding myself if
I think there's a problem here there's
just a puzzle so I mean he's used in the
philosophy of mind in that way to kind
of dissolve some traditional puzzles in
a philosophy of mind obviously there are
lots of experts in the philosophy of
mind who don't like this approach at all
on your answers to the last questions
victim shine and maybe to a lesser
extent popper don't seem like very
savory people even if they're
intellectually brilliant and I'm
wondering if as a philosopher you think
there's any point where their
intellectual arguments lose strength if
as people they are perhaps not admirable
personally I don't think affects their
philosophy I mean they've been ad
hominem attacks on then and some of them
quite kind of justified but you would
like to think that the philosophy will
will not rule the day on the basis of
the ideas and I mean I think it's fair
to say about both of them as well that
they were interested it obviously they
had popper more than victims died and
had a kind of traditional ego but they
were interested in the pursuit of truth
and that lots of the rage in the debate
and the argument kept stemmed from that
motivation relevance from anything more
malevolent follow-up question well what
would you like people to get from this
book just an understanding of the two
arguments or anything more I mean I want
people to enjoy it really I mean it's
it's a strange book because well not
only is a whole book about ten minutes
but it's it's part biography it's part
about partly about the lives of these
two men it's partly history it's about
Infierno in the place of assimilated
Jews and in Vienna and it's about
Cambridge in that and what the
atmosphere of Cambridge was like just
after the war this where there was
rationing and this he was a very cold
winter it's partly about the philosophy
because what they fought about reflected
the central schism in twentieth-century
philosophy the importance or otherwise
of language and finally and just as
importantly it's a whodunit who said
what to whom and that's what the final
chapters about
David Edmunds is a journalist with the
BBC Vidkun Stein's poker is his first
book it's published by Ecco press an
imprint of HarperCollins visit
HarperCollins com for more information